the Silver Surfer is a Marvel character
that fans have been wanting in the MCU
for a very very long time and we don't
want one like in the 2007 Fantastic Four
movie where Galactus one of the most
powerful cosmic beans to ever exist in
the Marvel Universe was portrayed as a
cloud no we want the Silver Surfer that
is done justice in the MCU how's it
going everybody it's Warren and we may
be getting our wish according to reports
the Silver Surfer may be heading to the
MCU on the big screen with his very own
solo film and this report lines up with
other reports stating that we're going
to be getting a Fantastic Four movie in
2022 and the fact that Galactus tyrant
and Doctor Doom are all heading to the
MCU as well so we'll break down this
recent report but a reminder started a
new giveaway at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers I'll be givin away
an Xbox one or a ps4 at winners choice
to enter all you have to do is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment below with your favorite
superhero or villain also click the link
in the description for your chance to
win a Nintendo switch so this new report
stating that the Silver Surfer could
possibly be getting his own solo film in
the MCU comes from geeks worldwide calm
according to sources geeks worldwide
says that Marvel Studios is actively
developing a solo Silver Surfer film and
geeks worldwide speculates that it could
be Adam McKay who is developing it Adam
McKay co-wrote the very first ant-man
movie and he's also wrote and directed
other movies such as the big short vice
both anchorman films stepbrothers and
the other guys so Adam McKay is a very
capable writer and director and back in
2018 he expressed interest in directing
a Silver Surfer film back in 2018 he
said Silver Surfer is the one I want to
do man I would do anything to do Silver
Surfer because visually you could do
what the Wachowski x' did with Speed
Racer with Silver Surfer
at the same time there's a great
emotional story in there man where
Norrin Radd aka the Silver Surfer has to
make the choice to save his planet that
would be the one but I think Fox owns
the rights well now obviously Disney
owns the rights to the Silver Surfer and
not just the Silver Surfer but Galactus
and the Fantastic Four as well both of
which have been reported to be making
their way to the MCU relative
soon and again according to geeks
worldwide the Silver Surfer will be
getting his own solo film and this makes
perfect sense because this is what
Marvel does they build up characters
over time and if you build up the Silver
Surfer you're not just building up the
Silver Surfer you're also building up
Galactus recently there have been
reports that Galactus is going to make
his way to the MCU
he's been stated to take fan OSes
position being the next big bad villain
of the MCU and of course you have to
build him up over the years just like
they did with Fanus well the silver
surfers appearance in the comics was as
Galactus 'as Herald the Silver Surfer
would serve as Galactus is Herald until
eventually he would turn on his master
to help defend Earth a solo Silver
Surfer film could mark the first mention
of Galactus in the MCU but hopefully it
will not be done like the 2007 Fantastic
Four film the rise of the Silver Surfer
in fact in this solo film the Silver
Surfer may not be Galactus is Herald
anymore there are many different ways
that Marvel could take a solo Silver
Surfer film and hopefully they do it
right
geeks worldwide were also the ones that
reported that a Fantastic Four movie
could be coming in 2022 so hopefully the
Fantastic Four movie sets up a Silver
Surfer movie but in the meantime let me
know what you all think about this news
would you be excited for a solo Silver
Surfer film or would you rather have him
introduced in a Fantastic Four film and
if you prefer a solo film what would you
like the story to be be sure to let me
know in the comments down below also
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
like the video and comment with your
favorite superhero or villain so you can
enter to win an Xbox one or a ps4 and
again don't forget to follow me on
twitter and click the link in the
description down below for your chance
to win a Nintendo switch as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof